Девочка-пай Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, das Podcast-Ofo, wo wir freuen, uns sehr, euch wieder begrüßen zu dürfen. Vor mir sitzt, wie immer, mit einem wachen und einem mühenden Auge, Florentin Wille. Ich freue mich nur so mittel, aber ich bin da und natürlich freue ich mich besonders, dass ich gegenüber sitzen darf von Doktor Stephan Dietze, muss man ja sagen. Mittlerweile ist das ja offiziell geworden, du hast offiziell dir einen Doktortitel erschlichen, möchte ich sagen. Du hast ihn natürlich laut gefeiert, aber ich rieche da Betrug. Hast du das auch mal gemacht, aus Gag hat jeder mal gemacht, ne? Sich mal irgendwas bestellt, auch Doktor Florentin Will und so. Ist es mal irgendwann aufgeflogen? War der Gag mal jemals lustig, Frage eins, war der Gag, hat der Gag jemals irgendwie nicht gezündet, aber auch Frage zwei und ist es mal aufgeflogen. Ja, dass man angeht, Professor Florentin Will und dann klingelt es so in der Tür, Herr Will, ihr Paket ist jetzt da und man öffnet und die Polizei ist da, zack, verhaftet, kein Professortitel, tschau, eingelockt.
Einfach eine Faust ins Gesicht, glaube ich, einfache Strafe dafür.
Aber was man da teilweise auswählen kann, Herr, Frau, Doktor, Professor, Papst, Hauptmann, Major, einfach so wie alle Bürgermeister, Comedy-Legende, Entertainment-Urin, ja, ganz merkwürdige Titel kann man da anwählen.
Die haben ja, naja, Urgestein, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, was hat ein Bürgermeister, weil ich finde, das Amt des Bürgermeisters, also jetzt in Städten wie Köln oder so, ist schon was Wichtiges,
aber so ein Landbürgermeister finde ich immer wahnsinnig lustig, weil die haben ja das gleiche Ego, also das gleiche Auftreten auch. Diese stolz geschwellte Brust, diese grosse Schere zum Eröffnung durchschneiden. Diese weirde Kette? Diese Scherpe. Ja, diese Scherpe, diese Metallkette. Und ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, was haben Bürgermeister noch wirklich zu tun in so kleinen Städten und so? Und dann, ich dachte mir, die haben auch nichts mehr zu sagen. Das ist doch irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, wie so Governor Sworn. Bürgermeister über Governor. Ja genau, das war das Übergebliebene, das ist Bürgermeister von Port Royal. So und dann haben wir gedreht in einem Gebiet, war ein bisschen ein ländliches Gebiet, und haben eine Location angefragt und die haben uns nicht erlaubt, da zu drehen. Dann hat er war, eine Woche später haben die wieder angerufen und gesagt, ja, ja, ihr könnt doch drehen. Und wir hatten, wie kann das denn jetzt sein? Kam raus, dass der Bürgermeister der Stadt mitbekommen, ein ganz kleines Dörfchen, mitbekommen hat, dass wir da drehen wollten. Und hat sich aber, weil sein Sohn die Serie mag oder sowas, ganz doll dafür eingesetzt, dass wir da drehen können, hat der Bürgermeister an Machtwort gesprochen, hat die, hat einfach, hat einfach die Pächter von diesem Ort einfach overruled, gezwungen. Er hat für Ausnahmezustand ausgerufen und gesagt, wir sind jetzt im Krieg und ich entscheide jetzt, was hier passiert und die dürfen jetzt hier gedreht. Ja, und dann haben wir da gedreht und er kam jeden Tag vorbei mit Fotografen.
Also erst war es noch süss, so ein kleiner Bürgermeister, kommt da angedackelt.
Und dann irgendwann war es aber auch nervig, weil er dann immer Fotos gemacht hat.
Und dann habe ich mich ein bisschen auch, also stellvertretend für die Serie, instrumentalisiert gefühlt für seinen Wahlkampf.
Ah, verstehe, okay.
So, demnieter, der kleine, nette Bürgermeister mit dem grossen Grinsen, das ist nämlich schon auch einfach ein Arschloch, ein Politiker-Arschloch.
Aber ich habe mal wieder gezeigt bekommen, Politiker haben noch was zu sagen.
Absolut, ich bin ja mit Benjamin Blümchen aufgewachsen, da war der Bürgermeister die höchste Autorität.
Da gab es keinen Finanzminister, AK-Verkehrsminister, Andi Scheuer, gab es nicht.
Da gab es den Bürgermeister und der war die Hauptinstanz, der hatte Sagen. Da gab es nichts drüber. Von daher, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne mich so schlecht mit Politik aus, ich könnte dir nicht sagen, was genau die Befugnisse eines Bürgermeisters sind und was nicht und was der Landrat macht und so, keine Ahnung. Trotzdem war ich wählen, war trotzdem schön zur Wahlkabine gewackelt, einfach weil es sich auch gut anfühlt. Ja, ich liebe es auch, sonntags was zu tun zu haben, weil sonntags hat man selten so wichtige Termine, die einem von oben so okkruiert werden. Das finde ich immer ganz toll daran. Und man geht an Orte, an dem man sonst nicht ist. Sonst nicht ist, eigentlich wollte ich Briefwahl machen, wegen aktueller Situationen, habe es natürlich verbasen, ist klar. Hier ist auch verbasen, ich habe es zerfrebelt. Bist du einer, der im Vorhinein schon recherchiert, oder lässt du dich die Wahlkabine dich überwältigen? Einfach so, show me what you got. Ich gucke ab beim Nebenmann. Ja, das ist immer das schönste Gespräch, so in der Wahlschlange so. Hey, was willst du? Wie viele Kreuze darf man machen? Wie viele Kreuze darf man machen? Eins pro Seite. Wie, Pro Seite? Pro Seite. Aber ist Seite auch, weil man kann ja manchmal knicken. Er guckt, die gucken. Lola, Wellen wählen, Demokratie, Wahlwahl, Demokratie, Fan, Fan. Stimmrecht, parlamentarische Demokratie, Wahlwahl. Nee, ich bin tatsächlich, ich informiere mich vorher, bin aber dann auch einfach ein strategischer Wähler. Sehr impulsiv aber auch? Nee, gar nicht. Ich wähle strategisch. Okay. Heißt immer, ich informiere mich vorher und entscheide mich dann für das Gegenteil, weil ich dafür gute Gründe finde. Nee, aber ich will meistens nicht die, ich will meistens so, dass da der Hintergedanke daneben steht. Mit wem ist die Partei, mit der ich mich am meisten identifiziere, müsste die denn koalieren können, sowas. Ah, also so tief bist du schon drin. Ist, glaube ich, albern. Ich bin noch auf dem Niveau, wer hat den coolsten Namen. Das ist bei mir immer noch so ein, ach ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber schon eins nach, wer hat die coolste Farbe. Ja, das stimmt, weil ich habe halt keinen Bock, die nächsten 16 Jahre immer so einen schwer auszusprechenden Namen zu haben, der dann so kompliziert ist. So ein einfacher Name, da bin ich dabei. Und neue Partei gab es jetzt Volt. Volt hat in meiner Strasse alles zuplakatiert und bin nicht immer vorbeigekommen. Sehr ansprechende Plakate, fand ich ganz tolle Slogans. Hat aber nichts mit Voltemort zu tun. Aber ich dachte die ganze Zeit, man kann auch eine Partei wählen, die Volt heißt. Das klingt wie so, das ist also, wenn ich eins aus Filmen gelernt habe, dann, dass sowas ein offensichtlicher Name eines Bösewichts ist. Ja, stimmt schon. Volt. Wir haben Volt gewählt. Wir haben Voldemort gewählt und wussten nicht, was dann passiert. Doch, wenn ihr Voldemort wählt oder ihnen folgt, dann ist schon klar, das ist ein bisschen wie der Todesstern. Ihr kämpft für das Böse. Umbrella Corporation, die wähle ich ungern. Ja, und wenn dann die Aliens kommen und sagen, ihr habt Volt gewählt und nicht so die Anti-Strom-Aliens, die dann uns helfen. Die Gleichstrom, die scheiß Gleichstrom-Aliens, die uns immer noch böse sind, dass wir uns für Wechselstrom entschieden haben und die immer noch wetternd. Haben wir uns entschieden jetzt eigentlich. Wir haben uns tatsächlich entschieden. Wurde auch nicht gewählt, aber ich glaube, da gibt es auch einen Film, wo ich mir auch denke, wow, gewagte Prämisse, Wechselstrom gegen Gleichstrom, das ist dann Tesla gegen Edison oder sowas. Das wollte ich auch immer mal machen. Und dann kämpfen die halt für Gleichstrom gegen Wechselstrom, wo ich mir auch denke, gibt es dann da eine coole Erklärung, weil ich weiß nicht hundertprozentig, was da jetzt passiert, aber... Sind ja mehrspielchen hinter den Kulissen. Ja, so Wechselstrom macht schon mehr Sinn einfach. Also das ist, glaube ich, die effizientere Variante. Gut, das ist aber auch einfach für dich, dich auf die Seite von Wechselstrom zu schlagen, wenn du schon weißt, dass wir uns für Wechselstrom entschieden haben. Also das ist jetzt, was sind da so die Vorteile, die dich überzeugt habe? Also ich bin bei Tenet die ganze... Nee, was sind da so die Vorteile, die ich überzeugt? Wechselström. Wechselschön ist einfach so, ist nicht so vorhersehbar einfach. Ich finde das andere ein bisschen langweilig. Und es ist natürlich besser einsetzbar für Dinge aller Art. Nee, wir haben noch 40 Minuten. Ach so. Du musst dich gar nicht beeilen. Ich dachte, ich wäre jetzt auf ein anderes Thema eingeladen worden. Nee, nee, wir müssen gar nicht, wir haben noch eine Zeit. Jedenfalls habe ich die Volt-Partei gewählt, weil die Markström, Markström, schön. Aber zum Thema Titel und Doktortitel, ich habe tatsächlich letztens, ich weiß nicht, ob du diesen Moment kennst, wenn in der Realität Dinge passieren, die man eigentlich nur aus Filmen kennt, wo man denkt, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass es wirklich passiert, so was ist mir letztens passiert. Weil du so ein Buch aus dem Regal genommen hast und dann kam so ein heller Schein vom Himmel. Genau. Ja, das sollte ich jetzt vielleicht lesen. Darauf war das jemand drauf. Das ganze Regal dreht sich so um und so ein Geheimgang entsteht. Was? Ich will nämlich immer in die Bücher, also wenn ich so im Buchladen bin und so, und dann schmökert man mal so rum, so, ach, schönes Wort schmökern. Ja, okay, Achtung, die Top drei Dinge, die in der Bibliothek passieren können, wenn man ein Buch aus dem Regal nimmt. Ich fange an mit Platz Nummer drei. Du nimmst ein Buch aus dem Regal und die entstehende Lücke dient als Fenster auf die andere Seite, wo eine junge Dame dich anblickt und eine Rom-Com entsteht. Ganz kurz, sind wir jetzt in Filmszenen, die in Büchereien entstehen können oder sind wir in, weil ich habe die Kategorie.
So klar will ich diese Top-Listen nicht definieren. Für mich sind Top-Listen immer dann gut, wenn sie möglichst vage gehalten sind.
Mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm.
Top zwei, du findest ein Buch, du nimmst das aus dem Regal, schlägst es auf und es fällt genau auf der Seite raus, wo noch ein Zettel drin ist vom Vorbesitzer dieses Buches.
Und natürlich liest man sich das durch und findet auch ganz spannende Sachen, vielleicht eine Handynummer, ich weiß nicht. Top 1, du nimmst das Buch aus dem Regal und das ganze Regal stürzt ein, alles stürzt ein, vier Studenten begraben, das war unsere Top 3 Dinge, die passieren können passieren können mit meinem Buch aus dem Bücherregal.
Aber ich warte immer darauf, dass ich ein Buch aus dem Regal nehme und dann kommt dieser helle Schein, der Harry-Potter-Schein, die Seiten. Ach so, ich dachte, das war jetzt eine Anspielung auf diesen anderen Film. Wie heißt er? In Infinity, Inversion, nee. Tenet. Ähm, eben nicht Insanity, Inception. Nein. Incident. Impeccableness. In Infinity. Mein Gott, der mit Lou Ferrigno. Der mit der gelben Katze. Hulk. Ja, nee, mit dieser roten Katze, die im Wohnzimmer immer rumhängt. Garfield. Nein, der Typ, der mit der Tenner-Familie. Alf. Alf, so, Alf meine ich. Da gibt es auch noch dieses Lichtschauen, dann stellt sich raus, dass es alles aus der Vergangen, aus der Zukunft kommt und die mit dem kommunizieren will und so. Du bist auf Alf nicht gekommen? Nee. Man sagt gern Alf. Alf. Was ist das dämlichste Wort, auf das man nicht kommen kann? Wer sind diese ovalen, weißen Dinger, die man so braten kann in der Pfanne? Ja, ich komme gerade nicht drauf. Shit, die Hühner, Huhn und dann legen, was legen die nochmal? Warte mal, hier die man so verteilt und so. Fuck.
Alf.
Aber ganz kurz, um das zu beenden, Dinge, die in der realen Welt nicht passieren, wo tatsächlich jemand gesagt hat, denk mir jetzt das aus.
Ah, guten Tag, Herr Ludenhofer, Doktor Ludenhofer, so viel Zeit muss sein.
Oh, ich dachte, solche Dinge passieren? Oh mein Gott, du hast es mitgeschrieben für deinen nächsten Film. Von der Realität inspiriert. Leute bestehen wirklich auf ihren Doktortitel. Ich fand es unfassbar, ich war wirklich für so einen Moment so, wow, das sind Dinge, die passieren. Das ist so, wie wenn jemand wirklich auf ein Auto schießt mit einer Pistole und das Auto explodiert in dem Risiken.
Und du denkst dir, das passiert wirklich?
Das ist wirklich was passiert?
Aber auch mit dem Spruch, mit dem Anhängsel, Suffix.
So viel Zeit muss sein.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn du, ich glaube, dieses so viel Zeit muss sein, hat sich einfach durchgesetzt unter pedantischen Arschlöchern,
einfach um so ein bisschen Menschlichkeit zu bewahren. Das ist für mich auf einer Ebene wie Wiedersehen macht Freude, wenn man so ein Lineal leiht oder sowas. Das hört man aber häufig. Wiedersehen macht Freude. Das tut hier weh. Wo weh? Hier so kurz über der Leber. Milz. Ist das die Milz? Ist das das Organ? Zeigst du auf die Milz. Ist das das Organ, das zuständig ist für Wortverbrechen? Das aufschreit? Miliz. Wiedersehen macht Freude. Wiedersehen macht Freude. Schmerz. Ja, das ist spannend. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man das sollte. Also das ist ja offensichtlich arrogant. Und niemand da denkt dann, wow, das ist Doktor. Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn du schon mal zweieinhalb Jahre investiert hast, um irgendwie den Doktor der Literaturwissenschaft zu bekommen, wenn du irgendwie so komparatistische Literaturwissenschaft Garfield gegen Alf, beide pelzig, aber sind auch beide süss, machst, dann will man schon, dass dann nach dreieinhalb Jahren man sagt, nee, jetzt aber auch hier der Doktor. Ich kenne es immer nur andersrum, dass Leute, die einen Doktortitel haben, sagen, ach, kannst du weglassen. Das ist doch viel cooler, wenn du den Doktor weglassen kannst, und er sagt so, ah, Herr Doktor Ludenhofer. Weil ich bin so ein Titeltyp, ohne Scheiss, ich würde das lieben, einen Doktitel zu haben, weil du kannst da so rumprollen, wie du willst und so betrunken durch die Gegend, Spiegel von Autos abtreten und so weiter und dann bist du aber Doktor. Ja. So Doktor der Physik werden wir ja nicht, wir werden dann irgendwie so sprachwissenschaftliche Kackdrecksdoktoren. Ja, halt irgendwie so viele so viel, irgendein Quatsch. Aber eigentlich so... Aber du musst das ja so ein Bachelor machen. Ja, aber so Kontrastsituationen stimmt schon, wenn du dann in so einer Verwahrungszelle bist und dann kommt der Polizist und sagt, Herr Doktor und lässt dich aus der Zelle, das ist ein merkwürdiger Moment. Mega. Wenn du so komplett angetrunken bist, so wirklich noch so Erbrochenes auf dem Jackett, auf dem Tweets-Jackett und du gerade irgendwie losgegangen bist und irgendwie Briefkästen zertrümmert hast, da kann man mal auch feine, subtile gesellschaftliche Kommentare. Vielen Dank. Danke. Ja, Entschuldigung. Ich habe überlegt jetzt, wenn ich nochmal einen Master machen würde, weil ich halte nicht so viel von Master und Bachelorarbeiten und sowas. Ich glaube, das ist so eingegroovt, es funktioniert so gut, ohne sich wirklich Mühe zu geben. Oder, also man kann da so gut, ich habe noch keine Bachelorarbeit gelesen, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, die ich wirklich gut fand. Nee, ich auch nicht. Also, weil die sind immer alle so, die sind ja Bachelorarbeit. Es werden immer erstmal vier Seiten lang Dinge erklärt, die man schon kennt. Der Hand ist nie geil und du bringst auch nicht die Wissenschaft weiter oder irgendwas. Das liest ja auch danach niemand wirklich. Aber Master-Tieze ist schon Master-Tieze, so viel Zeit muss sein. Gerade das Bachelor ist halt fast eine Beleidigung, finde ich. Das stimmt, eigentlich müsste man nicht mit Bachelor anreden. Bachelor-Tieze, ja. Bachelor-Tieze, Bachelor-Tieze. Das ist eigentlich das Erbärmlichste, was man machen kann. Herr Tieze, Bachelor-Tieze. So viel Zeit-Arts-Tietze. Aber jetzt habe ich überlegt, weil ich davon wirklich so wenig halte, dachte ich, weil Master ja doch kunstcool wäre, und ein Doktor-Titel in der Verlängerung ja auch, so eine Ghostwriting, man lässt sich diese Sachen schreiben, von den Seiten, gut Gut, Betrug finde ich da gar nicht so weit weg. Also mit dem Wissen, dass ich mir jetzt jegliche Kredibilität wegnehmen sollte, sollte ich noch mal irgendwann mit Master machen. Aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass ich mir die schreiben lassen würde. Ja. Weil wem will ich was beweisen? Der Wissenschaft? Nein. Nein. Mir? Nein. Wissenschaft ist durch. Mir auch nicht. Ich mache es nicht für mich. Ich mache es für den Titel. Du machst es nur für den Schein. Ich mache es für den Schein. Ja, also in doppelter Hinsicht. Schein im Sinne von Lappen, aber auch im Sinne von Ausstrahlen. Heiligenschein. Ja, genau, dafür mache ich das. Und deswegen verstehe ich nicht so ganz, also ich verstehe voll, dass das Leute machen, ganz ehrlich. Weil das ist doch, ich könnte das ja, ich könnte ja eine Masterarbeit schreiben. Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt, das kann jeder behaupten, der sich das schreiben lässt. Hier wird eine Bachelorarbeit geschrieben und dann muss man halt ein paar Seiten mehr schreiben und sich ein, zwei Gedanken mehr machen. Glaube ich, überhaupt nicht, das könnte man hinkriegen.
Aber ist es nicht besser, eher so auf so einen Ehrendoktortitel zu spekulieren oder so, dass man irgendwie so die Katze vom Dekan rettet?
Vom Konsul.
Vom zweiten Konsulen rettet und dann sagt er, ja, Kraft meiner Macht als Erzherzog gebe ich Ihnen jetzt hier einen Doktortitel. Herr Doktortitel, danke, danke. Ich äugle eher auf den Ehrendoktortitel, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also ich habe den konventionellen akademischen Weg hinter mir gelassen und ich äugle eher auf den Ehrendoktortitel. Nee, du hast ihn nicht hinter dir gelassen, du hast ihn irgendwo weit weg von dir liegen lassen, verrotten lassen. Ich habe ihn verloren. Ja. Ich habe ihn verloren. Ja, aber es ist nicht so schlimm. Aber jetzt frage ich mich, weil das gibt es ja jetzt bei so, wie du sagst, ich will es für den Schein, für den Lappen. Jetzt angenommen, ich möchte mal so einen Bootsführerschein machen. Und es ist ja im Prinzip, machen wir uns nichts vor, ein Joystick. Ein Boot zu lenken ist wie ein Joystick. Oder Hagen, da sehe ich schon die Nautiker in die Tasten hauen und uns Hassbotschaften schicken. Ich sehe die schon, wenn wir den Boden anfahren. Dann musst du einen Knoten machen, wo du dein Boot festmachst, dann hast du einen Joystick und gibt es Gas und rechts und links und oben und unten. Also Motorbootfahren ist da wirklich nicht so schwierig. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Naja, aber was machst du, wenn du ein Schiff in Seenot triffst? Musst du dem helfen? Wenn ja, wie? Was passiert? 1-10-0 anrufen und sagst du... Wo kommen die geretteten Leute hin? So, das ist ja alles auch so Seerecht. Wo kommen die geretteten Leute hin? Ja, so Seerecht, dann so, was ist mit internationalen Gewässern? Was ist, wenn du einen Schatz findest auf internationalen Gewässern? Mir geht es ja erstmal nur, ich will auf den See fahren mit dem Boot. Ich will jetzt nicht... Du bist ja verantwortlich. Du hast ja auch die Pflicht, Leute in Seenot zu retten, so wenn du da irgendwie vorbeifährst. Das musst du ja wissen. Ich will nur zollfreie Ware verkaufen. Du willst einfach nur schön Weisswein, Vino Bianco, schön irgendwie ein paar Instagram-Bilder knipsen. Ja, genau. Aber jetzt denke ich mir, weil das System Bachelorarbeiten, Masterarbeiten und so weiter ist so ausgefeilt, das zu verhälschen, kann man jetzt auch einfach so einen Motorbootführerschein. Kann das jemand für mich machen? Und da muss man dann hingehen und erscheinen und so. Und ich will den nicht, man kann ihn bestimmt noch im Darknet bestellen oder sowas. Ich dachte aber, kann jemand, der so aussieht wie ich, da hingehen und auf meinen Namen den Motorbootführerschein machen? Ja, wie ist denn dieser Schauspieler, der so heißt wie du, dieser Brandon Fraser? Brandon Fraser? Nein, der hat auch einen Trichterbrust. Kann ich Brandon Fraser für dich den Motorboottest machen und dann, wenn er ihn hat, müsste er halt irgendwie so einen geheimen Treffpunkt festlegen unter so einer Laterne, einem Park, wo er die dann auf die Bank legt und dann geht und dann kommst du und nimmst den. Dann sagt man aber, dann rufe ich noch Brandon und dann dreht sich um und ich sage, wie läuft's denn? Nobody's called Brandon here, I'm Stephen Teets. Ja, okay, dann geht er weiter wieder und ich sage, nee, im Ernst kurz, wie läuft's denn in deiner Karriere? To be honest, it could be better. A lot of commercials in Japan, but... Okay, und dann fängt er an, viel zu viel zu reden. Okay, ich habe nicht mal Zeit für ein Okay, es ist nur ein Okay, ich habe zu wenig Zeit für das O. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. Aber geht, wir haben ja unsere Kollegin Julia, hat ja mal erzählt, dass sie, glaube ich, in Thailand war oder sow sowas und man dort auf einem Markt ganz viele gefälschte Dokumente kaufen konnte, also Bahncards, Kreditkarten, alles mögliche. Alles mögliche konnte man sich fälschen lassen, wo ich für halt winziges, für einen schmalen Taler, wo ich gesagt habe, warum lässt du dir nicht eine Bahncard 100 fälschen, das ist das Beste, was man sich fälschen lassen kann. Sie war zu ehrlich, ehrliche Seele, lohnt sich vielleicht irgendwann mal, aber momentan ist sie minus durch ihre Moral. Ich hätte gesagt, gib mir die Bahncard 100 und du zahlst und sparst dir 1.000 Euro und dann hast du dann so eine thailändische Bahncard, was ideal war. Und da hätte man vielleicht auch so einen schönen Motorbootsführerschein sich auch wegsnacken können. Die Bahncard 100 kostet 1000 Euro? Nee, kostet mehr, 2000, 3000 Euro, so. Kommt drauf an. Unter 25 kostet nochmal weniger, glaube ich. Aber ist schon teuer. Das sei denn. Unglaublich teuer. Aber echt mega. Ja. Ich glaube, das ganze System, und die werden uns nicht mehr so über gedacht haben. Aber so ganz glaube ich das nicht, weil es gibt so viele Rabattfunktionen und so, und diese Bahnrabatte, die sind schon relativ exklusiv, dieses 25, 50, 100 Prinzip. Ist das so gut? Aber zählt das auch für Hotdogs eigentlich? Also wenn du eine Bahn kein 100 hast, kriegst du dann auch Hassabahnbistro. Du hast weder Bahnbistro noch Sitzplussreservierung, glaube ich, drin. Das ist natürlich hart. Das ist natürlich ein Wermutstropfen, der ganz bitter mundet. Wermut liegt auch eine Pflanze? Ist Wermut nicht ein Gift eigentlich? Ruf mal Philipp Hauptmann an, unser Giftbeauftrag. Ruf mal der Charité an Oh, Tages aktuell! Yes! Yes! Wir brauchen auch wieder einen Gast. Ja, wir brauchen auch jemanden, der sich richtig auskennt. Was ist denn mit Christian Thielemann? Du meintest als Head of Guests, bist du da dran? Vor einem halben Jahr hast du gesagt, ich bin an Thielemann dran. Ich bin ihm auf der Ferne. Ich habe schon die ersten vier Ziffern seinerynummer. Ich bin noch ein bisschen mit Brandon Frader zusammen auf so einer Schatzsuche. Ich bin so einen Kilometer von ihm entfernt. Ich bin hinter ihm, ich habe so eine Spur aufgenommen, aber ich bin so einen Kilometer hinter ihm. Ich bin noch ein bisschen hinter ihm. Wir sammeln so in so einer Vermächtnis der Tempelritter, ist das der Film von Brandon Frascher, artigen Verfolgung und Schnitzeljagd. Schnitzeljagd für den Augen, tollesre, finde ich. Sammeln wir noch Hinweise. Wir gehen zu Kirchen, wo dann irgendwie ein Statum nach rechts zeigt, dann gehen wir nach rechts und da ist dann ein Totok-Stand und der sagt uns, nein, nein, nein. Und dann sage ich erst, wie nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist die Zahl neun. Und dann ist die nächste Ziffer von Christian Thiedemanns Handynummer die neun. Mega gut. Guter Film. Guter Film. Pitch das mal. Du pitchst ja auch manchmal tatsächlich Filmideen und coole Filmsachen, oder? Ja. Wie hoch ist dein Bedürfnis, ein Pitch mal so als Gag, so die dümmste Idee aller Zeiten zu pitchen. Einfach nur, um zu gucken, wie die Leute von Universal Pictures einfach reagieren. Einfach mal sagt, wie ich die dümmste Idee, wirklich so Finding Christian Thielemann, irgendwie sowas. Und dann einfach nur zu gucken, wie die langsam nervös werden. Hast du da ein Bedürfnis, zuckt es dir da? Ich finde es ja, generell. Aber in vielen Situationen hat man ja dieses Bedürfnis, jetzt einen Gag rauslassen. Jetzt mal einfach kurz einfach mal lassen. Aber es ist noch nicht vorgekommen leider. Die sind aber auch nicht so, sind nicht diese klassischen Pitch-Situationen, in denen ich zumindest immer gelandet bin. Es war immer so ein, ja schick uns doch mal was und dann schickt man den PDF über fünf Seiten. Ah, dann sieht man nicht, wie sie reagieren. Und dann ist ehrlich gesagt, also PDFs und Gags habe ich eh schon, kriege ich nicht so zusammen. Ist es das humorfeindlichste Format, Dateiformat? Ich würde sagen, ja. PDFs helfen nicht, also wogegen die Textdatei, die gemeilene TXTDatei, unglaublich lustig ist. Also allein schon durch dieses pedantische, sehr pragmatische Umfeld. Aber auch ein bisschen unbeholfen. Aber auch unbeholfen, unfertig und so leicht, weiß ich nicht, dahingeschrieben, toll. Wohingegen Pages schon anfängt, Schwierigkeiten zu machen, Indiesign gar nicht mehr funktioniert und PDFs auch ganz schlecht.
Ja, PDF, da wird glaube ich gar nicht mehr
geschmunzelt, da wird nicht gelacht, humorfeiniges
Format auf jeden Fall, aber
ich mag PDFs ja ganz gern, also ich, weil man so
das ist wie so ein Versiegeln,
wie so ein einlaminieren, das ist jetzt so.
Da ist ein Rechtsstreife da drin,
aber der ist nicht so schlimm. Das ist das nächste,
was der moderne Mensch an so einer Granit
Tafel hat, für die sich ja auch Gott entschieden hat.
Oder hat Moses die geschrieben, diese Steintafel mit den neuen Gesetzen, glaube ich, waren es. Oder hat Kam die Zehn Gebote? Aber hat Gott die geschrieben oder hat Gott die den Mose diktiert? Nee, Gott hat ihm Moses gesagt.
Hey, pst, pst, komm mal mit einem Meißel und einem Hammer und zwei grossen Steinplatten. Und zwei Frossants und nicht in keinem Kaffee. Und einem koffeinevollen Kaffee auf den Berg Sinai, bitte. Und dann, du willst mir irgendwas diktieren, mhm, warte mal ab. Ja, zwei Steinplatten. Kannst du mir etwas machen, was für lange keines mehr ist? Du willst mir irgendwas diktieren warte mal ab ja immer ein Geheimnis um etwas zu machen was schon lange keines mehr ist du willst mir schon wieder irgendeinen Scheiss diktieren ne eine von deinen scheiss Rom-Com-Ideen die ich viel zu unzufangreich formuliert habe aber bring trotzdem den Meisel mit nimm mal den Korrekturmeisel auch mal zur Vorsicht mit nimm Nimm mal drei Tafeln mit. Genau wie so Freunde einladen und sagen so, und bring mir der Siedler von Katan mit. Und die so, nee, wollen nicht schon wieder einen scheiß Spielerabend machen. Nee, bring nur einfach mal mit. Aber bring mal mit. Nimm mal lieber drei Tafeln mit. Ich weiß, ich bin mir beim Paar geboten und nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Und dann diktiert er den, es dauert ja eine Woche, bis du das alles gemeistet hast, und dann kommt er runter. Was für eine Schwachsinnsidee, ey. Ich habe mir seit langem ein Brettspiel gekauft. Ja? Ja, und ehrlich gesagt freue ich mich da total drauf, weil es ist genau, ich wünschte, das hätte es eher früher gegeben, und ich bin total heiß darauf, das zu spielen. Man kann es nur einmal spielen, schon genial, dass man das mal einmal, dass man mal sagt, fuck it, das muss man nicht andauernd spielen können, einmal reicht. Die Idee ist nämlich, ein Fall, ein Fall muss man lösen. Und es gibt keine Regeln, ausser, dass alle Hinweise, die du brauchst zum Lösen des Falls, in dieser Kiste sind. Das sind zum Beispiel E-Mails, die dir irgendein Journalist schreibt, es geht um so einen Mordfall oder so eine Brandstiftung oder sowas, dann so wirklich Fotos vom Tatort. Das ist schon ein Unterschied, ob es eine Brandstiftung oder ein Mordfall ist. Vielleicht beides sogar, vielleicht hat die wurde ja jemand angezündet, ganz brutale, weiß ich nicht genau. Und du musst einfach, dann kannst du quasi wirklich einfach klischeehaft so eine Korkwand aufbauen und dann alle Hinweise dranpinnen und so, dann gibt es Handynummern, die kann man vielleicht sogar anrufen. Also du kannst wirklich viel machen. Und die sind nicht geordnet, diese Hinweise. Die sind gar nicht geordnet. Die sind gar nicht geordnet. Du musst sie selber irgendwie organisieren. Nein, es ist wie genau, jemand hat dir das hingestellt und du musst das den Fall lösen. Und ich finde es fantastisch. Ich freue mich da so drauf. Und das spielst du auch alleine? Nein, das spielst du auch mit mehreren dann, weil du musst ja viele Sachen sichten. Also du musst auch viele Mails lesen, die der Journalist schreibt. Du musst, keine Ahnung, du musst auf jeden Fall viel sichten und durchgucken und nachrechnen und ob das also stimmt. Und Zeugen auch sagen, durchgehen. Also das ist schon Arbeit und deswegen glaube ich, ich spiele immer so zu zweit, dritt. Aber was eine tolle Idee. Coole Idee. Und dann kann man es ja einfach weitergeben. Und wenn man das durchgespielt hat, kann man es einfach verschenken. Das ist eine gute Idee. Wie heißt das? Für unsere gierigen Hörer? Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Unsere spaßgierigen Hörer? Muss ich nachreichen. Ich habe den Namen vergessen. Rachen nicht genug bekommen von Spaß. Ja, ich kenne einmal kurz meine Amazon-Bestellliste. Oh, jetzt ist es peinlich. Aber jetzt musst du alles vorlesen, was auf der Bestellliste ist. Auf der Amazon-Bestellliste ist? Alles, die letzten zehn Produkte will ich hören. Was bestellt Stefan Tietze? Oh, da musst du aber auch auflegen. Im grossen Online-Warenhaus. Nee, das kann ich nicht machen. Nee? Nee, das ist, nein. Wie viele, ach dann sag mir, wie viele der letzten zehn Produkte kannst du hier nicht nennen? Eins. Ja, doch kann ich schon nennen. Sehr menschlich. Also ich habe... Wir sind aber eigentlich kein menschlicher Porto. Also eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn. Okay, ich habe zehn, soll ich die letzten zehn? Hau raus. Aber du musst es auch mal haben. Ich kann es nicht abrufen hier. Die letzten zehn Amazon. Tu es. Okay. Briefklammern aus Metall zum, das sind so Papierklammern.ierklammern. Ja, die kennst du, die sind zum Aufhängen von Bildern. Ah, okay, so Klemmen, so diese schwarzen Klemmen. So Papierklemmen, genau. Okay. Dann für meinen Wassersprudler, meinen Sodastream, eine neue Flasche. Nochmal Kohlenstoff oder was? Genau, ne, ne, eine neue Flasche, einfach so eine Wasserflasche, die man da dran macht. Da kann man ja keine, nicht jede Flasche drauf machen, sondern spezielle Flaschen. Und da kann man nie genug von haben. Du lebst ein aufregendes Leben, ich darf sagen. So, dann. Papierklemme und eine Flasche. Ja, dann das unangenehme Kondome. Okay. Aber ist ja menschlich. Wie viele? Tausend? Wie viele? Nee, so diese Box halt.
Wie viele sind die? 36er Box.
36, okay.
So, dann das flexige Monatsalbum von Audible.
Aber das zählt glaube ich nicht.
Dann der Film, alle Mörder sind schon da.
Clou.
Auf den ich sehr Lust hatte.
Fanastischer Film, macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß.
Tolles Genre. Ich mag generell so Mörder-Mystery sehr gerne.
Dann für meine Cousine,
die jetzt ein Jahr nach Schottland geht,
das Monopoly Scotland Special Edition.
Dann das Spiel,
das heißt Detective Stories,
ID Venture,
und das ist der erste Fall,
Adlerstein heißt der erste Fall.
Ah, okay.
Dann die Mew-Tutu-Fahrradklinge. Mew-Tootu? Die Mew-Tootu-Fahrradklinge. Also das Pokémon. Miau-Tootu vielleicht auch, M-E-O-W. Das hat nichts mit Pokémon zu tun. Ich glaube nicht, nein. Nein, es hat nichts mit Pokémon zu tun. Aber es gibt auch Mew-Tootu als Pokémon. Mew-Tootu? Ja. Nee, es ist die Fahrradklinge, es hat nichts mit Pokémon zu tun, es gibt auch Mewtwo 2 als Pokémon. Mewtwo 2?
Ja.
Nee, es ist die Fahrradklingel, es hat nichts mit Pokémon zu tun, es ist einfach eine Fahrradklingel.
Und die hieß Bell laut, weil wegen laut, aber ist nicht laut, das hat mich geärgert.
Und dann noch das Buch Die Enden der Parabel von Thomas Pynchon.
Wow, das ist eine gute Woche, oder?
Ja.
Ist das für einen Zeitraum nicht schlecht? Ja, das war jetzt so einen Monat. Ich bestelle nicht so ein bisschen. Nicht schlecht. Ein kleiner Einblick in Stefan Fils' Welt. Ja, wieder Einblick, ehrlich gesagt. Es klingt vor allem, seit ich mir das auch gedacht habe, ja, Kondome. Ich wünschte mir aber von dir nächste Woche auch die Amazon-Liste. Aber bestelle jetzt keine unangenehm... Ich nachliefern. Ja, jetzt bestell ich nur noch Twinkies. Jetzt bestellst du coole Sachen, damit es... Oh, ja. Oh, okay. Ja, aber Amazon ist immer so... Ja, na ja. Na ja, gut. Wird schon, aber... Aber das, glaube ich, kann ich jetzt schon, ohne es gespielt zu haben, empfehlen, weil ich finde allein die Idee schon so toll. Die Idee ist richtig cool. Ich glaube, wenn man das in der Gruppe macht, ohne dass es jetzt einer der Gewinner ist, glaube ich, ist vielleicht auch für manche Freundeskreise eine ganz gute Idee, vielleicht mal ein Spiel zu spielen, das keine Gewinner hat. Naja, ich glaube, man findet und gewinnt zusammen halt, man kann es auch nicht lösen. Aber ich stelle mich davor, wie man dann anfängt, auch zu rauchen bei dem Spiel, so harten Whisky am Tisch oder so. Oder an dem Fall zerbricht. Genau, wie in jeder guter Detektiv muss er irgendwie persönliche Traumata haben, die dann rauskommen, die mit dem Fall irgendwie aufgewickelt werden. Da kommen die Kinder rein ins Büro und dann sagt die raus, raus, raus, Kinder weinen, da kommt die Frau. Die Ehefrau, Stefan, du hast ja seit drei Tagen nicht so entnommen, dieser Fall frisst dich auf. Dieser Fall frisst dich auf und ich sage, nein, ich muss ihn lösen. Wenn es mir noch um eine Sache geht, dann will ich diesen Fall lösen.
Ich nehme jetzt die Kinder und gehe zu Tante Margaret.
Genau.
Okay.
Oder so einen Zettel am Telefon.
Took the kids to Aunt Margaret.
Und du mir so einen Papierkarton mit noch mehr Zeitungsausschnitten und so.
Also falls ihr euch fragt, warum die nächsten Wochen keine Folgen mehr kamen, Stefan Tietze ist abgestürzt, Bachelor Tietze ist abgestürzt in ein Loch der Kriminal-Digtime. Aber zum Thema Humor, ich versuche auch ab und zu den einen oder anderen Gag zu landen, was mir schwerfällt, vor allem im Medium Instagram. Und zwar gibt es eine ... Da habe ich auch die Humorschelle noch nicht klingen lassen. Und zwar gibt es immer einen Gag, weil ich habe ja erzählt, dass ich, tausendste Mal, dass es jetzt erwähnt wird, eine Französisch-Lern-App habe, wo ich immer meine Vokabeln eintrage. Und dann schreiben mir manchmal Leute und schreiben, hey, wie heisst denn die App, wie heisst denn die Französisch-Lern-App? Und dann schreibe ich ihnen den Namen der App zurück. Und in 90 Prozent der Fällen antworten die Leute mit Merci. Und dann antworte ich, was? Und noch nie hat jemand diesen Gag verstanden und alle antworten, ja, danke, danke für den Tipp. Fuck, das kann nicht, scheiß ernst sein. Und ich werde diesen Gag durchziehen bis an mein Lebensende, bis ich mal so die Tränen schießen aus den Augen Emoji oder irgendwie sowas kriege. Aber ab jetzt wird es ja bekommen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht sage ich das hier auch nur, um den Fluch mal zu brechen. Das glaub ich nicht. Weil mich macht das innerlich wirklich was Florentin, ihr hört doch nicht, also ihr folgt Florentin und das glaube ich also nicht. Wie kann man denn überhaupt mitbekommen, dass du eine französische Lern-App hast, wenn man nicht deinen Humor mag? Ich verstehe es auch nicht. Dann kommt man ja gar nicht bis dahin. Ich verstehe es auch nicht. Und dann folgt man dir wegen deines Humors und dann schreibst du zurück, Merci, um was?
Und dann sagen die, hä, warum haben die das, aber das ist doch weird.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht, mich macht das krank, mich frisst das innerlich auf, wenn mein Humor auf unfruchtbaren Boden fällt, wenn ich da einfach nicht ankommen und ich ziehe das durch, mir ist das egal, ich ziehe das einfach durch. Merci. Hä? Was? Was heißt das? Was heißt das schreiben sollen? Was soll das bedeuten? Vielleicht muss ich jetzt in Phase zwei nochmal ein bisschen den Deutlichkeitshebel nochmal hochstellen auf, was möchtest du mir damit sagen, was soll das bedeuten. Übrigens ganz kurz, um das noch abzuschliessen von letzter Woche, vielen Dank an alle, die uns wegen der Ohrwürmer geschickt haben, noch mal eine dicke Entschuldigung, viele haben sich beschwert, dass die Folge sehr nervig war, ist korrekt. Mittlerweile ist die Playlist online, also alle Ohrwürmer wurden gefunden, es gibt auch ein paar Songs, bei denen es mehrere potenzielle Lösungen gibt, die wurden alle aufgenommen. Dua Lipa, Break My Heart, Mega Song. Dua Lipa, auf jeden Fall großer Dua Lipa-Fan geworden. Tatsächlich, weil ich eher, ich kannte die Person, bevor ich die Musik kannte. Und dann mochte ich die Musik auch, weil ich die Person mochte. Und zwar habe ich Dua Lipa gesehen bei Ellen, Ellen DeGeneres. Und die hatten so ein Format, was richtig cool ist, wo dann halt so Stars auf die Strasse gehen und mit Leuten reden, aber in den Lyrics ihrer Songs. Also die die Lyrics ihrer Songs sagen, wie normale Umgangssprache und dann einfach mit Leuten reden. Und dann Dua Lipa einfach auf jemanden zugeht und sagt, did the heartbreak change me? Maybe. Und halt einfach solche Sachen raushaut in einem normalen Gespräch. Und ich fand das so lustig einfach. Und ich fand, die hat das so gut gemacht irgendwie, dass ich mir dachte, die finde ich sympathisch. Und dann fand ich die Musik auch okay. Deswegen grosser Dua Lipa-Fan. Aber das ist spannend. Dein Musikgeschmack ist nette Leute. Ja, primär von netten Leuten einfach so. So nette, witzige Leute, die irgendwie auch mal bei so einem Scherz auch dabei sind. So, ja, sowas. Und seitdem liebst du Adele, Motorhead, Dua Lip. Ich liebe Adele, Elvis, John Hurt, ACDC, das sind einfach nette Jungs. Aber auch weird, also ein Playlist ist einfach ein Haufen something. Ja, einfach so, mit denen wäre ich gern befreundet. Weil es ist ja oft so, du kennst das ja wahrscheinlich aus dem Bandumfeld, wenn Freunde Musik machen, dann unterstützt man die, egal was die für Musik machen, auch wenn die Musik grottenschlecht ist, sagt man, ich fand es cool, ich finde, das hatte was. Und man findet auch, weil man es auch irgendwann anfängt zu glauben selber, findet man auch immer Dinge, die einem dann vielleicht reingefallen. Genau. Und bei mir ist es andersrum. Ich will mit, genau, es ist ähnlich, wenn ich Leute sympathisch finde, finde ich die Musik auch gut, einfach um die zu unterstützen. Weil ich schreibe dann auch irgendwie auf Instagram viel mit Dua Lipa und schreibe dann auch so, hey, good song, cool Auftritt, Ellen DeGeneres und so. Was kam da bislang zurück? What? Was kam da bislang zurück? Tatsächlich weniger, steht immer nur Red. Also sie liest meine Nachrichten extrem schnell. Ich schicke eine Nachricht und nach drei Sekunden hat sie es gelesen, aber sie antwortet nie. Also Mixed Signals, ich weiß es nicht, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Du hast die Lens irgendwie. Du liebst meine Nachrichten extrem schnell.
Aber antwortet halt nicht. Also irgendwie komisch, ich weiss auch nicht, was bei der los ist gerade. Naja, egal. Jedenfalls toller Song, den glaube ich Tim reingebracht hat, wo ich direkt an so einen alten Funk-Song gedacht habe, da wir auch nicht draufgekommen sind. Ja, gut, sorry. Aber, kleinesmankerl noch, Nachtrag, wenn man so ein Running Gag dann schon, so meme-artig, weil die nicht zu finden sind, weil die keine Lyrics haben, weil du kannst halt nicht du-du-du-du-du googeln. Ja. Oder durch diese kindliche du-du-du-du-du-Sprache setzt es sich auch eher in den Kopf. Ja. Dann kennt man ja, wenn man zum Beispiel die Lyrics nicht weiter weiss, hat man oft einen Orbum. Oder wenn nur ein Teil eines Songs geht, ist es ein Orbum. Genau, wenn man es nicht beenden kann. Wenn es ein Loop ist. Wenn es immer wieder versucht, es zu beenden, aber es nicht weiterkommt und es immer wieder wieder hoch ist. Richtig. Und so durch diese kindliche Du-Du-Du-Du-Du-Sprache, glaube ich, und man keine Lyrics hat, an die man sich klammern kann, hat es auch vielleicht einfach ein höheres Orbum-Potenzial. Es war auch echt schwer, diese ganzen Ohrwürmer zu finden. Ich bin gescheitert bei jedem, am Ende hast du, glaube ich, die meisten gefunden. Aber es ist echt super schwer, weil ich habe dann irgendwann auch angefangen, so Playlists durchzuhören mit die schlimmsten Ohrwürmer oder so. Es gibt schon eine deutsche Playlist mit auch vielen deutschen Songs, irgendwie Ohrwürmer des Todes, habe ich mir die komplette Playlist durchgehört, was natürlich eine absolute Katastrophe ist. Und danach? Du weißt halt, du ruinierst ja deinen Tag so. Und der Tag war ruiniert. Aber mein ganzer Tag nach der Aufnahme war ruiniert. Ich habe den noch mit zwei Freunden verbracht und wir liefen den ganzen Tag rum, weil ich den natürlich sofort nach der Aufnahme gefragt habe, wie heißen diese Songs, habe alle vorgesummt, weil ich noch alle im Kopf hatte und den ganzen Tag sind alle Leute mit den Ohren rumgelaufen. Das war wirklich furchtbar. Ganz schlimmer Tag. Ganz, ganz furchtbarer Tag. Wir entschuldigen uns an alle, die auch ähnlich furchtbare Tage hatten. Uns hat diese Folge den Tag ruiniert, euch hat diese Folge den Tag ruiniert. Wir möchten uns entschuldigen, aber manchmal muss man halt auch durch schwere Zeiten zusammengehen. Ja, so eine Podcastbeziehung ist nicht immer nur alles toll und lustig, nein. Geben und nehmen. Das ist aber manchmal furchtbare Scheiße. Manchmal muss man auch nehmen können und einfach sagen, ich nehme jetzt diese Probleme an. Muss auch gehen. Und da, ich glaube, es hat uns aber enger zusammengebracht, diese ganze. Die Hörer und uns? Die Hörer und uns, ich glaube, sind jetzt näher. Die, die jetzt noch da sind und uns, ja. Ja, ja. Hat es näher zusammengebracht. Danke, danke für eure Treue. Tim und Tom Steiner. Wollen wir mal sagen. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei seid. Tom Steiner. Ja. Aber alle Wörter, die du gesagt hast, sind drin. Window, Coffee, alles war drin. Wörter sind drin, nicht unbedingt in der Reihenfolge, aber die Wörter sind auf jeden Fall drin. Also ich würde sagen, ich habe es genailed, absolut alle Lyrics, voll. Ja, aber sehr lustig, ich behaupte, wenn man das mit klassischen Songs machen würde, würde ich es hinkriegen. Nein, derselbe Fehler nochmal, die Hybris, das Wachs klebt noch an den Armen, Stefan, tu's nicht, tu's nicht, nein, tu's nicht, nein, stopp, die Sendung wurde vor vier Jahren abgesetzt, stopp, stopp, gehören hier auf, nein, warum sind sie auf dem Sender, wie sind sie überhaupt vor die Kamera bekommen, wie funktioniert das, ich habe aber eine geniale Idee zum Thema Lyrics, Achtung, Startup-Idee. Und ich bin ein wohltätiger Mensch, ich spende kein Geld, ich spende Ideen. Und falls irgendjemand von euch da draußen... Gott, das solltest du nicht sagen. Ich spende natürlich auch viel Geld. Was solltest du noch weniger sagen? Ich spende natürlich kein Geld. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Also, deswegen haue ich meine Idee raus. Und zwar, jeder liebt Karaoke. Jeder liebt es, Songs mitzusingen. Das Problem ist, die meisten Leute haben keinen Bock auf so ein Karaoke-Umfeld. So, jetzt machen wir Karaoke. Sondern man singt halt gerne einen Song mit, wenn er gerade im Radio läuft oder wenn man im Auto unterwegs ist, Roadtrip, und der Song Song kommt und würde gerne mitsingen, man kennt aber halt die Lyrics nicht.
Deswegen meine Idee, eine kleine Box, die sowas wie Shazam integriert hat, das heißt die mithört und automatisch hört, welcher Song gespielt wird und jetzt haben wir zwei Komplexitätsstufen, entweder diese Box zeigt den Text einfach nur auf dem Screen an, so, was ideal ist, weil du hast die Box dabei, kann natürlich auch als App funktionieren, aber das Handy hast du ja oft dann irgendwie, vielleicht als Navi oder so im Auto oder so. Hast du diese Box oder ich gehe noch einen Schritt weiter, Stefan Tietze. Kleiner Beamer. Kleiner Beamer. Diese Box ist ein kleiner Beamer. Das habe ich ja mal in Folge, ihr könnt ja nachgehören, zwölf oder so vorgeschlagen, weil ich dachte, ihr seid im Auto. Ja genau, wirft es an die Scheibe. Genau, an die Scheibe. Das hast du vorgeschlagen. Das ist aber schon ewig her. Doch, weil ich es immer dachte, weil wie geil, es macht so Spaß im Auto das vorzusehen. Ich trage diese Idee seit Monaten mit mir rum, erzähl Leuten davon, was das für eine geile Idee ist und die ist eigentlich von dir. Du bist eigentlich mein Steve Wozniak. Nee, kann ja sein, dass ich es nie erzählt habe, kann auch sein. Du bist mein Eduardo Severin, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Aber ich meine, ich habe es auch mal im Podcast erzählt, aber es ist das Beste im Auto zu singen, das Allercoolste. Ich kenne aber die Lyrics zu nur zwei Prozent der Songs, die ich selber kenne. Das ist ein Statement. Nee, pass auf. Nein. Nee, pass auf. Ich kenne nur die zwei, ich kenne, hä? Nein. Mehr? Nein, weniger. Nein, ich kenne die Lyrics von zwei Prozent der Songs, die ich kenne. Nein, tust du nicht. Tust du nicht. Schreib mal alle Songs auf, die du kennst, und dann gehen wir dir mal eins, so, die Folge dauert länger. Nimm mal alle Songs, schreib mal alle auf, auf keinen Fall. Die ich gut kenne. Ja gut, jetzt ist die Definition schwammig genug, dass du dich da durchmogeln kannst. Alter Bachelor-Trick, das funktioniert so nicht. Aber ich finde die Idee geil, weil zum Beispiel, ich singe gerne in der Badewanne. Wie sieht das aus? Nicht schön, aber ich lese in der Badewanne, höre Musik und meine Bluetooth-Box, habe mein Handy in der Hand und lese vom Handy die Lyrics ab und sing mit. Viel cooler wär's, wenn ich einen Beamer hätte, der das an die Badezimmerwand wirft und man beim Duschen morgens, stellt euch vor, ihr geht in die Dusche morgens, macht die Musik an, die Box springt automatisch an, sobald sie Musik hört, wirft den Text an die Wand und du kannst sofort mitsingen. Ja, wenn du nicht gerade durch deine Seifen, Duschdass getränkten Augen noch gucken kannst. Naja gut, Schmerzen muss dabei sein. Aber im Auto ist es doch auch wahnsinnig gefährlich, weil ich will ja, wenn ich fahre, auch mitsehen können. Es gibt nämlich was, weil ein Auto von einem Kumpel, der hatte so ein Toyota, so ein weirdes Auto, und das hatte so eine ganz lustige Idee gehabt, dass oben quasi, da geht es ja dann so über dem Armaturenbrett
drüber, geht es dann so
zur Windschutzscheibe.
Und da war so ein Projektor,
also da war einfach nur
die Geschwindigkeitszahl spiegelverkehrt
und dann sah man die geil in der
Windschutzscheibe, hat sich so gespiegelt.
Dann denke ich mir, das ist doch möglich einfach.
Du brauchst einfach eine länglichere Box,
wo der Text gross zu sehen ist, also eigentlich so wie so ein Lineal, wo der Text so durchläuft, Zeile für Zeile. Und dann legst du das hin, hinten in die Windschutzscheibe, und da sieht man das dann gespiegelt. Ja, geniale Idee. Mach da was draus, Leute. Du musst doch einfach nur, stimmt, eingebaut was haben wie eine Songerkennung. Die Frage ist halt, brauchst du eine Internetverbindung oder nicht, weil ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz so trivial, einfach mal sämtliche Lyrics, naja, so Lyrics sind ja nicht gross, also der Teiko ist ja sehr klein, du musst die halt nur erkennen, das heißt, du brauchst da irgendeine Software drauf, die das erkennt und dann einfach matcht mit dem Text und anzeigt und dann halt noch, weil das ist nämlich das Ding, viele werden jetzt in die Kommentare schreiben,, ja gibt's doch schon, dass man sich den Text anzeigen lassen kann oder so, aber ich will, dass der auch mitgeht mit dem Song, das heißt, er muss nicht nur den Song erkennen, sondern er muss auch checken, wo im Song sind wir gerade und man kann ja eigentlich eine Geschwindigkeit für den Text. Aber da verstehe ich Spotify wirklich nicht, warum Spotify das nicht hat. Krass nicht. Die hatten das mal, dass man sich die Lyrics anzeigen konnte.
Ja, und diese Funfacts, Geschichten hinter Songs. Ja, mittlerweile Funfacts, ist mir egal. Ich will den Text. Ich will den Text haben. Aber keine Ahnung, aber da ist glaube ich noch richtig viel Potenzial. Und jetzt ganz kurz, dein jämmerlicher Kritikpunkt von wegen, Leute werden sterben, werden im Autobahngraben landen. Mein Gott, die zwei, drei Jährchen, wo wir unsere Autos noch selber fahren, die sind mir doch egal. Die sind noch eingepreist in der Entwicklungszeit. Zwei, drei Jährchen sitzen wir gelangweilt da, starren uns an, haben uns nichts zu sagen und fahren viereinhalb Stunden nach Lübebüro. Und würden gerne Dua Lipa singen. Das ist nämlich der Punkt, worauf es hinausläuft. Ja, ich finde es super. Lass es machen. Und zwar ist es die Podcast-Ufobox. Die Puffobox. Die Puffobox, und alle finden es nicht, weil alle, wie heißt diese Box mit den Songtexten und so, und wir denken es immer, nein, weil es einfach... Lyric Genius, Genius Text. Warum, weil das wäre doch geil, wenn unser Merch plötzlich einfach auch Produkte sind, die es so noch nicht gibt. Stimmt eigentlich. Ja, Podcast-Ufo-Merch ist diese k Merch ist diese krasse Box. Ist eine schöne Idee, weil eigentlich ist Merch ja Dinge, die wirklich sehr etabliert sind, wie ein T-Shirt. Ja, aber langweilige Sachen. Wir finden damit das Reiter nicht neu, aber damit schon. Und ich denke mir, wie geil, weil so fühlt man auch heute wieder an Podcast. Ich fände es auch gut, wenn gewisse Produkte es ausschließlich als Merch gibt. Also ich habe ja mal von dem FC Köln Toaster gesprochen, aber stellt euch vor, Toaster gäbe es ausschliesslich von FC Köln. Jeder Toaster der Welt ist FC Köln gebrandet, ob man will oder nicht, aber die sind halt die einzigen, die das herstellen. Da machst du immer, wenn das Toast hochkommt. FC Köln Ja und die tosten den Toast auch nur in Form von dem FC Köln Logoogo, wo du denkst, du hast außenrum irgendwie einen Rand der Traurigkeit, wo deine Marmelade einsetzt. Stark verbrannt, krebserregend den Geist Bock Hennis. Ja, aber das finde ich gut, wenn alle Lyric-Boxen Podcast-Ufo gebrandet werden. Ja, auch deine gute Französisch-Lern-App, die du machst, wo man mit vielen Funktionen, aber auch die Pufo-App. Und niemand findet das. Ganz schlechtes Branding. Da sitzen Leute dran. Ich habe lange kein Developer-Gespräch mehr geführt mit meinen Entwicklern. Ich weiß nicht, was die machen, ob die nicht schon ihr eigenes Social-Network-Drama haben, dass die abgespalten sind. Der eine hat das Konto eingefroren, die zwei Zwillinge haben irgendwie ihr eigenes Ding gemacht. Wahrscheinlich so ein ganzes Drama ist da schon passiert, rund um diese Erlern-App. Ja, du hast es noch nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe es nicht mitbekommen. So wie dann Zoom-Call machen nach Silicon Valley, gucken, was da so geht. Die besten Geschichten kriegt man ja oft nicht mit, sind ja unter der Erde. Ich glaube auch. Also wenn, oder wäre es mir sehr langweilig, wenn ich die besten Geschichten mitbekäme immer, dann würde ich sagen, was ist eine langweilige Scheißwelt. Ich glaube, die besten Geschichten passieren, auch in anderen Ländern, glaube ich. Ich glaube, Deutschland ist kein gutes Land für Geschichten, hier passiert nicht so viel. Ich glaube, die besten Geschichten fallen auch gar nicht auf, weil niemand zukommt. Oder weil sie zu krass sind, uns zu erzählen. So geheim. Geheime Akten? Das glaube ich daran, glaube ich auch nicht. Aber es werden ja immer wieder geheime Akten treffen nicht. Ja, weil wenn es ein Land gibt mit geilen geheimen Akten, dann noch die USA. Aber ich glaube, dass der Bundespräsident, der hat dann vielleicht auch so einen kleinen Ordner oder sowas, wo geheime Deutschland-Akten drin sind. So vier Post-it-Notes, die mal jemand weggeheftet hat. Ja, da ist doch, also ich glaube nicht, weil ich glaube schon an unsere Demokratie. Ich glaube nicht, dass hier was unter den Tisch gekehrt wird, was wirklich irgendwie spannend wäre, mal, weil sowas wie Area 51 zu stürmen, wäre in Deutschland das Lameste der Welt. Naja, ich glaube schon, aber jetzt so Sachen wie, wie das Olaf Scholz vielleicht Cum-Ex gedeckt hat und so, da glaube ich, gibt es schon irgendwo, gerade in so diesem Bankenzeug und so. Ich glaube, da gibt es einige Geheimnisse. Und ja, ich habe mal einen Zeitungsartikel gelesen, ja, okay, und da bin ich jetzt auch stolz drauf. Nee, ich meine, das ist aber auch sehr lame. Naja, wenn du den Artikel gelesen hättest, wüsstest du, was da für Summen im Spiel sind, die ich jetzt nennen könnte. Das ist natürlich ein großer politischer Skandal. Ja, politischer ist ja nach, genau. Aber dafür würde jetzt niemand Stoss Bellevue stürmen. Also da würden wir jetzt nicht alle wie Naruto ... Der ist ja nicht der Bundespräsident.
Der ist ja etwas anderes.
Ja, ja, da ist er etwas anderes.
Ich weiß, dass er etwas anderes ist.
Finanzminister.
Genau.
Aber ...
Wo ist das Auto?
Hier, das ist ja dieser alte Tweet, den man auch kennt, dass Breaking Bad in Deutschland
wäre einfach lame.
Ich habe Krebs, Krankenkasse zahlt, alles gut, Breaking Bad, wenn die passiert.
Ein bisschen, glaube ich, ist auch so, funktioniert ja auch Deutschland so.
Es ist alles ein bisschen zu gut geregelt. Es funktioniert alles irgendwie zu gut.
Wir können ja mal zusammen ins Archiv gehen, weil diese Geheimakten müssen ja dann veröffentlicht werden, so nach 50 Jahren oder so.
Können wir mal gucken, was so vor 50 Jahren geheim war? Ja gut, vor 50 Jahren. Dann können wir mal gucken. Das sind wahrscheinlich so DDR-Sachen oder so halt. Deutschland ist schon krass eigentlich. Du, ich habe ja in Berlin direkt am Checkpoint Charlie gewohnt. Das heißt, jeden Tag, wenn ich rausgegangen bin, um mir meinen Milky Way Roll zu holen, habe ich deutsche Geschichte erlebt.
War ich da direkt am Ort, wo der Kalte Krieg sich zugespitzt hat, wo wirklich geschichtsträchtige Dinge passiert sind, wo Touristen standen und gesagt haben, wow, knipp, knipp. Ich dachte, Milky Way Roll gibt es nur in Amerika. Nee, nee, hier, hier ist das passiert und ich laufe da durch in Schlappen und hole mir meine Morgenrolle. Also, dass deutsche Geschichte lebt, will ich sagen. Nicht, wohin will. Aber nee, es stimmt schon. Also, das ist schon echt spannend. Das ist schon echt spannend. Aber wo man tatsächlich sagen muss, ich habe mir überlegt, wie lernt man Geschichte? Weil Geschichte, es ist ja alles miteinander verflochten. Und ich dachte, die beste Idee ist eigentlich, man fängt irgendwann an und arbeitet sich dann nach hinten. Also du fängst an, Zweiter Weltkrieg. Und dann denkst du, habe ich. Und dann arbeitest du dich davon zurück, Weimarer Republik. Und dann denkst du, ah, jetzt check ich mehr, wie das passieren konnte im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und dann, ah, Erster Weltkrieg, ah, jetzt check ich, warum die Weimarer Republik so war. Und dann gehst du immer weiter zurück eigentlich. Aber jetzt habe ich wieder vergessen, warum wir der Zweite Weltkrieg. Jetzt habe ich wieder vergessen, jetzt muss ich wieder von vorne ein Kreis. So jetzt bin ich immer. Zeit ist ja auch immer im Kreis. Aber mein Problem ist, dass ich halt so moderne Sachen dann nicht mehr habe. Also die DDR zum Beispiel habe ich wenig Ahnung. Wirklich wenig Ahnung. Ja, habe ich auch nicht viel Ahnung. Wirklich wenig Ahnung, was da, klar, man kennt so die ganzen Gags, Running Gags, irgendwie ha ha ha, so durch Humor wird ja viel transportiert auch irgendwie, so mit den Bananen und Spreewaldgurken, so halb checkt man es, aber wirklich fundiertes Wissen ist da nicht da. Da fehlt eine gute Doku, so, es gibt ja jetzt diese gute Doku über den Vietnamkrieg, über O.J. Simpson, ich brauche so eine fünfteilige, siebeneinhalbstündige Doku, wo das einmal durchgeballert wird? Tom Hanks als Erzähler wäre gut, kein Muss, wäre aber gut. Aber sowas einfach mal durchballern, so an einem Wochenende. Du hast das Gefühl, du hast es wirklich durch... Bei Geschichte bin ich wirklich auch ein bisschen raus. Ja. Kann ich mir... Das ist sehr schwierig. Aber hast du das Gefühl, du hast es gut durchdrungen? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee, ich meine so, auch Zweiter Weltkrieg, Weimarer Republik. Nicht wirklich, nee. Und vor allem allem man liest dann andere Sachen und dann merkt man so, das habe ich alles noch nie mitbekommen. Dann in Krüger so Druck kommen kann. In der Konferenz und so und man checkt es nicht. Es ist zu viel. Und man denkt sich auch, wo, also ich meine die Frage, die alle Menschen sich ja stellen müssen, ist, wofür benutze ich meine Zeit? Ach so, ja. Also ich habe so jeden Tag habe ich so zwei Stunden Zeit, die ich für eine Zeit verwenden kann. Was mache ich damit? Und jetzt sagt der eine, ja, ich lerne halt 30-jähriger Krieg, 40-jähriger Krieg, 50-jähriger Krieg. Einen von dem suche ich mir aus, 10-jähriger Krieg, so überschaubar. Da fange ich erst mal an. Das ist der Krieg light, das ist auch einfacher für Kinder. Genau, Anfänger, Anfängerkrieg, wo auch die Leute damals im Krieg gesagt haben, das ist recht reich zu verstehen, oder? Wir kämpfen gegen die Schweden und wir mögen uns halt nicht. Ne, wir mögen uns nicht, guckt die jemand an mit den dicken Bärten, so, das mag ich nicht. Und ja, die Schlachten sind relativ klein, so 1000 gegen 500. Überschaubar, auch keine strategischen, grossen Dinge, kein Dolchstoss, kein nichts. Wir laufen aufeinander zu. Einfach aufeinander zu, die eine Seite gewinnt,
1-0 gewonnen.
Also das ist ultralär zu verstehen.
Wohingegen heute sage ich, Historiker in 100 Jahren,
vergiss es, kein vergiss es, wirst du nicht verstehen.
Allein mit Social Media so, wer hat was getwittert,
alles kann gelöscht.
Oder gerade heute, weil so gut dokumentiert ist.
Ja, aber es ist ja alles, nee, das wird nicht dokumentiert.
Twitter ist irgendwann gelöscht.
Versuch mal als Historiker in 100 Jahren, alte Tweets zu finden. Ich glaube, es geht. Archive.org oder was, scrollst du dich da durch? Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr. Ich meine, klar, vielleicht so von Präsidenten, die Tweets werden irgendwo archiviert. Werden die Tweets von Präsidenten irgendwo in einem amerikanischen Staatsarchiv ausgedruckt, abgeheftet? Die werden die mal ausgedruckt, abgeheftet. Ich kann mir das wirklich vorstellen. Es gibt ja bestimmt irgendeine Behörde, die irgendwie beauftragt ist, Geschichte zu sammeln, den Papst zu archivieren. Den Papst zu archivieren. Und dann werden alle Papst-Tweets auf Deutsch, Latein, Twitter-Papst auf Latein? Manchmal, glaube ich. Manchmal. Nur Dienstag. Dienstag ist Latein. Ja, mach da mal den Rechtschreibcheck. Latein Dienstag. Und kann man dann auch auf Übersetzen klicken? Kann Twitter mit Latein übersetzen? Klar, Twitter kann alles. Aber alles schlecht. Ey, die Google-Übersetzung ist mittlerweile richtig gut, wirklich. Man hat sich da kaputt gelacht, immer so, hohoho, Google-Übersetzung. Ich finde die immer noch scheiße. Die ist richtig... Ich finde die immer noch scheiße. Wisst ihr was, ich schwöre auf einen anderen Übersetzungsdienst. Der kommt aus Köln, DeepL. D-E-E-P-L, DeepL. Und die Idee ist mega. Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden. Die haben nämlich eigentlich nur einen Algorithmus geschrieben, der das Internet durchforstet nach Seiten, die es auf verschiedenen Sprachen gibt, die also schon mal professionell übersetzt wurden. Und ich glaube, die haben das so geschrieben, wenn du dann auch von Deutsch auf Englisch machst, die checken halt nicht nur, die übersetzen nicht die Wörter für sich, sondern die checken den ganzen Satz im Kontext, weil die das Internet durchsuchen, nach wo ist der Satz schon mal genau so geschrieben worden, übersetzt worden. Und das ist total genial, weil du kannst einfach, manchmal schreibe ich wirklich Mails vor und die kannst du eins zu eins kopieren und übersetzen und so reinkopieren ins Mailprogramm und abschicken. Da musst du nichts mehr verändern. Bei Google Translator muss ich immer noch wirklich komplett neu schreiben. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, irgendwann wird Google Translator einfach DeepL aufkaufen und so. Aber es ist eine Kölner Firma. Lustigerweise bei mir, da bin ich neulich noch vorbeigekommen. Ah, hier sind die. Winst du dann auch manchmal? Da habe ich gewunken, gesagt, gute Arbeit, habe ich so einen Daumen hoch gezeigt. Gute, gute Arbeit. Die sind mich cool. DeepL ist fantastisch zum Übersetzen, kann ich nur empfehlen. Ich erinnere mich gerade an einen ganz gruseligen Moment aus meiner Kindheit. Also was heißt Kindheit, kurz nach dem Abitur war ich irgendwie bei einem Freund unterwegs und dann sind wir da hingelaufen zu seinem Haus und es war eine Gegend, wo ich noch nie war und er meinte, hier wohnt der Herr Lüdenhofer, mein Deutsch-LK-Leiter. So und dann bin ich vor dem Haus stehen geblieben und das Haus eines Lehrers ist eh schon mal so, das ist ein Mensch. Es waren so zwei schwarze Hunde davor und so ein Nebel. Ja und dann denkt man sich so, da wohnt man und dann habe ich so halt so mehr als Gag, ich war damals schon humoristisch sehr gefestigt, habe ich halt so gewunken dem Haus. So, relativ lange habe ich dem Haus gewunken. Und dann im Weggehen sehe ich, dass tatsächlich der LK-Leiter im Fenster steht und mich anguckt, den ich da vorher nicht gesehen habe. Ich habe einfach nur dem Haus so gewunken, als hilarious Gag. Mein Kumpel hat sich kaputt gelacht. Da schwingt ja auch viel mit Gesellschaftskritik. Sollten wir nicht alle ein bisschen offen und zueinander sein, umgehen? Normalerweise winkt man ja Menschen zu. In dem Fall habe ich diese Erwartungshaltung jetzt aber dadurch gebrochen, dass ich nicht einem Menschen gewunken habe, sondern einem Haus zugewunken habe. Was ja gar nicht in der Lage ist, das zu erwidern. Korrekt. Und damit diese Situation, die man kennt, durch diesen Kniff ad absurdum gefühlt hat. Du hast es wirklich ad absurd absurdum geführt. Wodurch ein humoristischer Moment entstanden ist,
der sich die Spannung, die durch diese abstrakte Brechung entstanden ist,
wurde entladen durch Lachen, Zwerchfell.
Schallendes Zwerchfellgewackel.
Zwerchfellkontraktion, die in ein...
Oh, ich lern gerade Spanisch, Zwerchfell heißt Entranja.
Du lernst Spanisch? Ja. Que pasa? Äh, was? Ne, wirklich? Warum nicht Französisch? Ne, weil ich ja schon Spanisch kann. Ich habe ja so eigentlich, ich habe ja vier Jahre oder so in der Schule Spanisch gehabt und habe dann alles vergessen und habe mich erinnert und war auch manchmalulich mal wieder in meiner Heimat und habe dann so alte Spanischhefte durchgeblättert, wo ich seitenweise fliessend Spanisch geschrieben habe. Ja, es ist gruselig. Es ist gruselig, alles vergessen, ja gut, Schulsystem funktioniert, bla bla bla. Nein, man vergisst einfach Dinge, wenn man die nicht einsetzt. Und jetzt habe ich bei Duolingo wieder angefangen, Spanisch zu lernen, was unfassbar viel Spaß macht, weil man kann sich dann einfach, man macht so einen Test, man sagt, man hat schon mal Spanisch gelernt, dann machst du einen Test, dann wirst du gerankt und dann fängst du irgendwo an. Ja, aber kannst du jetzt nicht warten, bis unsere App rauskommt? Ich meine, die Podcast-UFO-Vokabel-App, kannst du jetzt nicht auf andere Apps umsteigen, die jetzt hier indirect promoten im Podcast? Und ich glaube, ich lerne sogar besser Englisch dadurch, weil die App auf Englisch ist. Und ich lerne jetzt, das ist ganz weird, weil ich übersetze jetzt einmal mehr. Das ist wie so ein bisschen Stittelpost. Es geht auch viel verloren, weil ich immer erst von Spanisch auf Englisch übersetze, sondern von Englisch auf Deutsch. Naja, aber cool. Und ja, aber wie planst du dann dein Wissen zu festigen, dass du nicht wieder alles verlierst? Also willst du dann auch sagen, einmal in der Woche, was heißt Ball? Elbal. Einmal in der Woche schaue ich dann schon eine mexikanische Sitcom. Stimmt, du bist ja nach Mexiko gereist. Bin ich auch mal. Aber nach Podcasts hören ist super. Ich habe jetzt so Filmpodcasts angefangen. Wenn die langsam sprechen, ja. Echt? Wenn die langsam sprechen, verstehe ich die. Ich tue mir total, obwohl ich obwohl ich schon eine Weile Französisch lerne, die sprechen so fucking schnell, das ist so hart, aber ich komme hin. Aber die sprechen nicht so schnell. Die sind entspannt? Nee, nee, nee, ich behaupte, weil das ist immer so ... Die sprechen schneller als ... Die ziehen halt einfach die Ass so lang. Ach so. Die machen einfach wenig Pause. Aber die prinzipiell reden die nicht so schnell. Die sagen immer kurze, so rapide Phasen, so kurze Sprints und dann ist ein langes Äh. Aber lernst du dann mexikanisches Spanisch oder spanisches Spanisch? Beides ein bisschen. Beides ein bisschen, weil du wirst ja jetzt dadurch, dass du Spanisch lernst, auch einen Akzent haben. Besserer Mensch, ach so.
Also ein spanisch sprechender Mensch wird bei dir raushören können, sprichst du Spanisch oder Mexikanisch.
Oder so ein spezielles Duolingo-Spanisch.
Oder halt irgendwas Merkwürdiges.
Du musst dich jetzt festlegen, genauso wie ich muss mich entscheiden, will ich Französisch klingen oder Quebecisch?
Ja, will ich wie ein Kanadier klingen?
Du musst dich nicht entscheiden. Als Spanier muss man sich entscheiden.
Aber ich habe jetzt ein guter Freund, das Argentinier.
Ah, spannend.
Und den verstehe ich gar nicht, gar nicht.
Und der, mit dem lerne ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen, aber der spricht einfach argentinisches Englisch, spanisch, was ganz ganz schwierig ist zu verstehen, weil der auch, der sagt dann statt Kaye Strasse sagt er dann sowas wie Kache und so. Und dann denke ich an ganz andere Wörter. Das heißt, du wirst dann wahrscheinlich eher einen argentinischen Einschlag haben. Von ihm vielleicht ein bisschen, glaube generell eher Spanisch. Finde ich gut. Aber ich mag das Mexikanische Spanisch sehr gerne. Das mag ich sehr gerne. Ja, ich wünsche dir ganz viel Erfolg dabei. Vielen Dank, ich bin auch beim Französischlernen. Dankeschön. Vielleicht können wir ja irgendwann diesen Podcast mal bilingual machen. Oder trilingual. Oder so trilingual. Oder quattrolingual. Dass wir alle Sprachen, die wir haben, in so ein Segment unterteilen. Und wenn wir dann noch Christian Thielemann hätten, dann wäre das der perfekte Podcast. Ich wollte bestimmt wieder Sprachen. Bestimmt. Naja, bis dahin müsst ihr euch mit weiteren Folgen begnügen, mit diesen Filler-Folgen. Man muss ja ehrlich mal sagen, es gibt ja nur wenige Folgen,
die die Storyline voranbringen.
Danach, inzwischen ist wirklich teilweise 20,
30 Folgen lang nur Filler.
Ja, das war eine klassische
Filler-Folge.
Wir freuen uns nächste Woche, die Storyline
wieder voranzutreiben.
Ich wünsche dir eine tolle Woche.
Wir sind ja schon ein bisschen petto.
Ich wünsche dir eine tolle Woche, haut rein.
Ich höre hier auch.
Und bis dann, macht's gut, wir heben ab.
Wir heben ab.
Bis dann.
Ciao!